holy crap everyone we got to talk about
that arrow revealed so just careful for
spoilers from episode 15 if you haven't
seen it yet we got to freak out about
that big reveal that's really like the
big thing to talk about but there's a
bunch of other stuff that happened in
this episode in the identity actually
holds true to the comic book characters
motivation even though they're switching
names I'll explain it it's a bit crazy
but I feel like they pulled it off
really well so I'm really happy with
what arrow is doing right now so there's
a new round of the flash ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so we just got to start this video by
saying okay big reveal
Adrian chase was revealed to be
prometheus there's no trick that's who
he is he's not secretly pretending to be
Prometheus that is his identity and if
you have an idea for where things are
headed they've been talking a lot about
Hannibal Lecter Silence of the Lambs
Buffalo Bill trying to manipulate Oliver
and team arrow in this really a
psychopathic way so we'll find out more
about why he's doing what he's doing and
why he's so crazy even though he's a
family man we saw he had a wife in a
previous episode so there's some weird
stuff going on here that they'll reveal
in the next couple of episodes is gonna
be crazy but top 10 WTF and comic book
Easter eggs so don't worry I'll explain
the big twist and the identity from the
comics because there's other vigilantes
stuff that's going on that's the big
twist so number 10 mister terrific's
teased fears one of the many comic book
things that they're pushing into so we
were waiting for it waiting for it
they finally activated it they are now
working the way he explains them is
comic book accurate both spheres do
different things it's only in the comics
that he's able to use them to levitate
there's a bunch of things that they
haven't worked up to like last season he
threw them at Roy they only blew up now
they actually do some of the comic book
things so we'll get to the point where
they're eventually doing really crazy
stuff but we're getting closer to comic
book mr. terrific number 9 Thea is super
dark now totally turning into her mother
suggesting they throw Billie Malone
Felicity's dead boyfriend in a good cop
underneath the bus because he's totally
dead and he won't mind that was one of
my favorite things from Thea storyline
he's dead he totally won't care about
this and then she also suggests they
used Pandora to blackmail one of the
councilmen to vote for Oliver
using his wife's suicide against him to
get him to vote for Oliver just a worst
thing ever so that's totally a move that
Oliver's mother would make in the early
seasons eventually she came around like
before they killed her off of this show
they tried to redeem her a little bit in
thankfully they did reveal at the very
end that she knew that Oliver had been
the hood the whole time so the writers
said that they're pushing Thea in the
direction that her mother went so we'll
see where they bring her back around but
the big explainer here for her leaving
the show like she's like I need to go
away and fix myself is that Willa
Holland the actress is only contracted
for 14 episodes of the 23 that they do
so she's just not gonna be in as many
episodes that's the reason so they wrote
her out for part of the season so she'll
be back eventually don't worry but
number 8 Felicity joins the helix hacker
group even after the fighting fire with
fire
we'll get you burned speech so a couple
people got that speech Oliver gave it to
Thea it seems like she listened to it
Felicity got it from Diggle that was
actually a great speech with Diggle and
it seems like she almost did not listen
to it like the way she justifies it is
is that Oliver is alive because he had
backup and they were fighting fire with
fire so it worked in that instance but
the whole hat tip here I think is that
Felicity is gonna work with this group
they'll do some good things and she will
totally get burned fighting fire with
fire will eventually get you burned so
it'll be interesting to see what form
that takes because diggle's like this
Pandora device is a weapon in the wrong
hands Felicity tried to argue that no
it's a good thing used in the right way
but what does this all sound like it's
building towards this helix group the
Felicity is working towards sounds an
awful lot like a different version of
hive like they'll totally have some
secret agenda that seems kind of evil
and it'll be some sort of hail Hydra
moment so even if they're not an evil
organization and it's not a Hydra type
twist something really bad is gonna
happen to felicity but number seven
Oliver's trial totally makes it seem
like Adrian chase has been manipulating
things this whole time to shift blame to
him like he's there to protect him he
barely spoke during the trial but when
the medical examiner who falsified the
evidence to protect the Green Arrow
comes forward
she says that Adrian chase told her that
it was the mayor
that was ordering her to do that so
there was this weird thing in the
episode where he kept trying to
manipulate Oliver knowing that he's
Prometheus like he's orchestrating
events this way so that Oliver will
throw himself under the bus like he
offers himself he's like you need to
throw me under the bus and he's like no
I'm not gonna do that that's the wrong
thing he wanted Oliver to throw the
green arrow under the bus so all this is
just misdirect like him pretending like
he wants to take the blame himself no I
would never do that I'm gonna choose
option three throwing the green arrow
under the bus that's the right thing to
do in the crazy thing about that is that
it actually was the right choice not
throwing somebody who didn't deserve it
under the bus now you have to remember
the Adrian chase technically didn't do
anything wrong even though he's
prometheus you have to assume that
Oliver doesn't know this yet but it's a
really weird situation so it's like
Oliver doing the right thing the thing
that he should do even though it's the
thing that Prometheus wants him to do so
it seems really bad even though it's a
good thing but number six vigilante
versus team arrow round one is just a
way to show you what a badass vigilante
is like they literally throw Thea like
she's a rag doll so it's a bit of a
misdirect like the voice that they're
speaking with sounds like this gravelly
Adrian chase voice so knowing the big
twist that vigilante is not Adrian chase
starts to make me wonder if this is a
woman so there were a couple key scenes
in the episode and the way their frame
looks the way they walk with their hips
just makes it seem very feminine so
we'll talk about that again in a second
because there was a lot of vigilantes
stuff in this episode especially with
the Prometheus storyline so vigilante is
a badass that was the whole point of
this scene just trying to take them down
improve why team arrow should not ride
in limousines together especially what
happened after last season when Felicity
almost died number five
flashback Oliver in the season one suit
always fun to see him in the season 1
suit again so he goes to get the
information from Kovar in the thing that
stuck out to me about this scene is that
you look at all those swords behind his
desk it looks really badass but it
reminds me of how Prometheus laid out
all his blades in the mid-season finale
so I wonder if there's some sort of
connection between the Blache backs
kovar in present-day Prometheus because
we know he studied with Talia al Ghul
and she's part of the flashbacks so
maybe Kovar also has something to do
with prometheus in the flashbacks - it
just seems like they're all coming
together all these things are starting
to connect in really interesting ways
but number four team arrow versus
vigilante round two
we use the t's fears to take them down
still not any clear evidence as to what
their identity is they're going to great
lengths to keep their face covered up so
that they can reveal somebody later on
like oh my god I never expected it to be
this person so one of the most important
things I think about this scene is
improving who vigilante is not because a
lot of people are like what if it's
Susan Williams because you know she's
kind of small she has an axe to grind
against Oliver but she was standing in
front of Oliver this whole time they
were fighting vigilante so it's
definitely not her
so that'll come back around again but
number three vigilante versus Prometheus
makes it seem like they're not working
together in Prometheus might try to use
vigilante to his advantage eventually
because vigilante seems like they have a
separate axe to grind with Oliver
because during the episode Adrian chase
manipulated evidence so that they would
go after vigilante because his whole
thing is that Oliver belongs to him he
gets to kill him first
but vigilante isn't having it they want
their own shot at Oliver regardless of
what prometheus is doing so it sounds
like they don't know each other and
they're not working together which i
think is really interesting so just
something else to file away in the
evidence drawer but because Prometheus
is such a master tactician he might try
to use vigilantes beef against Oliver to
his advantage in the future so number
two big WTF Oliver blames Billy's murder
on the green arrow throwing himself
under the bus making him number one on
the police's hit list so that means that
he's gonna have a really hard time doing
green arrow things in the city from now
on so like I said
Adrian chase Prometheus was manipulating
Oliver this whole time to make this
decision even though it was the right
thing for Oliver to do don't blame Billy
and don't throw Adrian chase the person
who Oliver thinks is the district
attorney
under the bus but of course the number
one WTF vigilante reveal is Adrian chase
so now the whole thing is about why
they're doing what they're doing why
he's being so crazy about this code
- Oliver what is all this manipulation
about does he really want to make the
city better because that seems to be all
of the heroes and all of the villains
thing this season making the city better
the way that they think that it should
be made better just to explain the big
comic book change that they made with
Prometheus and vigilantes character so
in the comics Adrienne Chase is a
character who becomes the vigilante he's
a district attorney but he has this
Punisher type twist where his wife is
murdered so he takes the name vigilante
because he can't get the criminals in
the justice system so he takes them down
after dark wearing a mask with guns he
goes super hardcore and becomes a big
Batman villain over time he goes way
over the line so Batman has to take him
down but he started out as a good person
so he's kind of like a Punisher type
character but what arrow has done has
taken Adrienne chase from the comics and
turned him into Prometheus on the TV
show and even though the names are
different the back story reads kind of
the same way so in the comics Prometheus
this Justice League villain who goes
after them trying to kill them all one
by one manipulating them
his parents were criminals that were
taken down and killed by the Justice
League so he vows revenge goes away
basically gets all these crazy powers
then comes back so it's kind of the same
thing with Adrienne chase so unless
there's another twist left to reveal
about the backstory it seems like
they're saying that Adrienne chases
father was just in Claybourne in part of
his reason for wanting to get it Oliver
is because he murdered his father but
it's got to be way more complicated than
that is not a simple revenge story it
wouldn't be this psychotic if it was all
about that so let me know in the
comments why do you think that
prometheus is going to such great
lengths to manipulate Oliver it goes way
beyond killing his father it has to be
something way crazier so what's gonna
happen next is I have some new Marvel to
post if you guys want I'll do that arrow
trailer then Friday morning I'll post my
spoilery Logan review video so make sure
you go see Logan this weekend while you
wait for that you can click here for the
Justice League test footage and you can
click here for my flash video thank you
so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys in the next video
you